foreign
s which one do you think is more
sustainable
the one on the left
or the one on the right
it's almost impossible to tell right
but there's actually one big difference
in these buildings
look inside
the building on the left is made of
concrete which means that it emitted
carbon dioxide during its construction
that's because the creation of cement
both releases CO2 and requires large
amounts of fossil fuels to heat up the
Kilns for the process
the building on the left
is made of wood which means that it
sequesters carbon
because trees use photosynthesis to suck
carbon dioxide out of the air and store
carbon in their wood fiber this building
has sequestered
3200 tons of carbon
that's like offsetting your round-trip
flight from San Francisco to New York
over 2200 times
I studied architecture in my undergrad
and in my first job out of college I
Source building materials for architects
while there I learned that concrete and
steel are the two most common commercial
building materials but that they're also
the two most carbon intensive building
materials on the planet
together they account for over 14
percent of global carbon emissions
and to make matters worse
we're also experiencing the largest wave
of urban growth on record
experts estimate that we will add 2.4
trillion square feet of space to the
World by 2060.
that's like adding a New York City's
worth of buildings every month to the
world for the next 40 years
so we have a growing population that's
becoming increasingly more urban
and our current building practices
contribute to a warming planet
what can we do
we can build more buildings like this
one
this building is made out of engineered
wood product called Mass Timber
and for the rest of this talk I'm
excited to tell you why Mass Timber is
better for the planet
better for people and a better way to
build in general
okay I know what you might be thinking
right
cutting down trees doesn't exactly
scream sustainability
that's because Timber has a branding
problem
how do you feel when you see a new
building made out of wood
you probably feel guilty thinking about
all the trees that had to be cut down to
make it
at least that's how I used to feel
but now I know that we should be cutting
down more trees to help fight climate
change
and here's why
wood is a renewable resource when
sustainably harvested
and mass Timber is made from sustainably
harvested young trees like these ones
not from trees from old growth forests
or national parks
Mass numbers made by gluing softwood
planks together into enormous panels and
beams that are as strong and fire
resistant as concrete and steel
these panels are 10 feet wide and 60
feet long and we can build up to 30
stories tall with them
to give you a sense of the carbon
numbers the average cubic yard of
concrete emits 400 pounds of CO2
while the same amount of Timber
sequesters six and a half times that
amount
when we cut a tree down to use the wood
in our buildings the wood stores that
carbon for decades and creates space for
a new tree to grow back in its place
continuing the sequestration cycle
experts estimate that if we transitioned
90 of our new construction to mass
Timber then we could store up to 20
gigatons of carbon in our buildings over
the next 30 Years
that's like offsetting the entire
airline industry during that time period
building with mass Timber isn't just
better for the planet it's better for
people too
take these two buildings
the one on the left was my college
science building and the one on the
right was my high school library
while they offered similar value props
they had a vastly different user
experience
my science Library
was pretty bleak
yes that is an actual study Carol in my
science Library
there's harsh fluorescent lighting
you're tucked in the back facing a
concrete wall
and I hope you brought a sweater because
take it for me it's freezing in there
used to leave these study sessions
feeling drained
compare that with my high school library
for a moment I'd like you to imagine
that you're in this study Carol
first you'd sit down and run your hands
over the warranty desk
feeling the bumps and grooves of
students past
you'd feel the sun beams radiating in
from the double height Windows warming
you up
and you might take a little study Break
by watching the sugar Maples Sway in the
breeze outside
I loved spending time in this building
because every time I did it felt like it
was time well spent
this building became my study tool just
like my pen and paper were
and I would leave this building feeling
accomplished
a study out of the University of British
Columbia has shown that the presence of
wood materials can lower the activation
of our sympathetic nervous system
the students who tested in the room with
wood furniture had a lower Baseline
condition and testing response than the
students who tested in the room with
plastic furniture
which suggests that by surrounding
ourselves with wood we can lower our
stressors
and improve our overall well-being
every major tech company in the Bay Area
has recently built a mass Timber
building or is in the process of
building one because they recognize how
transformative this could be
here's a recently completed example for
Amazon
here's one that's under construction for
Google
and here's YouTube's new planned
headquarters
each of these organizations recognize
the powerful effects of a less stressful
and more productive work environment
it literally adds dollars to their
bottom line
finally Mass Timber can be easier and
faster to construct
than concrete
that's because building with mass Timber
is kind of like building with Legos all
the pieces arrive on site ready to go
and ready to be installed quickly
this reduces the amount of Labor
required and the overall time to
completion
compare that with concrete which
requires large on-site labor forces and
extra weeks on the project to let the
concrete dry
take this real life example this is a
25-story mass Timber building that was
completed in Milwaukee last year and the
builders on this project estimate that
the mass Timber shaved three months off
of the construction timeline
that's a 15 Improvement in an industry
that views Innovation as kind of risky
and not something to be openly embraced
so when you think about a tree being cut
down
and you feel that Tang of guilt
I want you to think about these three
things instead
first mass Timber is a renewable
low-carbon alternative to concrete and
steel which paves away for a low carbon
future
second Mass Timber
is a natural material which boosts
productivity and lowers stress which can
make offices a happier place to work
and three Mass Timber is easier and
faster to construct which could be
instrumental in meeting the growing
housing needs of our population
so
when you're the CEO and you're building
your next office I want you to ask your
design team for Mass Timber
and when your new neighborhood plans a
multi-family development I want you to
ask the developer for Mass Timber
and when Stanford plans its next set of
dorms I want us all to ask the planning
committee for Mass Timber
because I ask you
what better way to fight climate change
while building for our future
than with a material that literally
grows on trees
thank you
[Music]